for millions of students Labor Day
weekend marks the end of summer vacation
and the start of another school year but
for the first time in a hundred and
eighty five years there will be no fall
semester at Green Mountain College in
western Vermont's the school fell victim
to trends in higher education that could
soon impact hundreds of other schools
brook silva-braga was there as the
College packed up for good when Robert
Allen became president of Green Mountain
College in 2016 he admired the
picturesque campus marveled at their
carbon neutral footprint and then gawked
at their balance sheet how soon did you
realize there might be a problem very
quickly I mean within the first couple
of months some mathematician by training
a financial person or realized that we
were going to come up short
the main problem was shrinking
enrollment by last year just 427
students remained on campus broke and
unable to find a school to merge with in
January Allen announced that the
school's 184th graduation would be its
last
I've had a long professional career not
all of it in education it was the
hardest thing I've ever had to do as you
can imagine many parents were really
angry kind of disappointed a lot of
people came here they like to build
relationships and like keep them going
not just to come here for a year to
pretty much intact what's left of Green
Mountain has a ghostly feel empty
classrooms empty dorms not even the pool
was filled and it speaks to how these
closures affect not just the school and
the students with whole communities this
is the only swimming pool in town it
wasn't really effectively a public
swimming pool the costs to run a college
keep going up new buildings higher
administrative costs but sluggish middle
class wages mean fewer Americans can
afford to pay I think this is something
people have trouble understanding
tuition is so high right shouldn't it be
easy to keep a college in good financial
health it would be that if anybody
really paid tuition so at Green Mountain
College this past year we didn't have
one full pay students really not wine so
in other words are published to ition
was roughly thirty six thousand five
hundred dollars and the
Everage student played just a little
over $12,000 we left Green Mountain and
headed towards Boston finding other
shuttered schools was as easy as pulling
to the side of the road
southern Vermont College in Bennington
Vermont also closed after the spring
semester this past spring also marked
the last classes for the college of st.
Joseph in Rutland just across the border
in Massachusetts Atlantic Union College
closed the year before and last spring
Newbury College here in Brookline mass
graduated its last class to in Boston at
Harvard we met Michael horn who's been
studying education and has a grim
prediction you think more of these
closures are coming absolutely I think
25% of schools will fail in the next two
decades a quarter a quarter act
absolutely they're gonna close they're
gonna merge some of them will declare
some form of bankruptcy to reinvent
themselves it's going to be brutal
across American higher education and
Horne says the problems colleges already
face finding enough paying customers
will only get worse we know that
families had fewer children after the
recession in 2008 which means that in
just a few years there's just going to
be fewer high school graduates and not
as many students going into college
fundamentally these schools business
models are just breaking at the seams
small schools in the Midwest in
Northeast are especially vulnerable and
Horne says new forms of education will
bring even more pressure I think we're
gonna see basically faster and cheaper
programs emerge I also think we're gonna
see a lot of mobile learning programs
come up where you can literally just pop
on your phone learn a few things and so
I think we're gonna see a lot more of
these sort of flexible affordable
convenient programs performance but what
these College alternatives would mean
for students and the families helping
pay their way that's less clear I have a
one-year-old at home yeah is he young
enough that society will have moved off
this idea of the degree in time that I
don't have to come up with 500 grand in
17 years this is the big question in my
household - I've got five year old twins
but I don't know I mean because there's
huge parts of the society that have to
shift with that it's not just
expectations it's how employers hire it
and huge reason people are going to
school is for social reasons you're
trying to sell e so what becomes of the
classic college campus no the asking
price is twenty three million dollars
president Allen says he's received
interest from international high schools
and a group hoping to educate veterans
another college here seems unlikely this
problem is not going away the
demographics are not going to change and
the fact that college is unaffordable
for a lot of folks is not going to
change in the near term for CBS this
morning saturday brook silva-braga
Poultney vermont
stark contrast to the college we did a
story on earlier this year called Berea
College which offers scholarships to all
of its students it has a 1.1 billion
dollar endowment be interesting to see
maybe they could teach a few lesson they
all handle scholarships in a different
way because they're in particular your
tuition is so much how are you going
broke not one student paid full tuition
last year they were all on scholarship
yeah and making money it's sad because
for some students that smaller college
is so important it's what they need to
get that education it's interesting to
see if some of these ways can keep
changing online learning I know for me
it was some of that social aspect of
college and learning how to be with
others it's important yeah College is
important